i had a bunch of questions about uh you
know the whole experience and whatnot
but uh you guys are not in the same
place am i to assume that this
relationship is did not work out or are
we still engaged okay slow down now well
now we're still together i'm just
working out of the west coast you're
here because someone in your
relationship has issued an ultimatum
okay great that's good to hear that's
good here because i feel like i was
rooting for you guys during this
relationship i know you guys knew that
you know you'd be going on to the show
and that you'd have a partner to help
you figure out your current relationship
when you found out that it was going to
be
more like a relationship than you
imagined or you knew what was your
initial reaction to that
well
being that i was the one that was
brought onto this and giving the
ultimatum i looked at sneak like are you
serious is this what we're really really
signed up for
and that in turn which i'm glad that i
chose madeline because we meshed so well
but had i not chosen her and chosen
somebody that we didn't mess with i
think i would have just hated the
experience all in all but
yeah this is something that i was not
expecting um and
i think any i don't think anybody was
expecting that to be honest well in all
fairness randall if you hated the
experience with the you know second
partner then that would make it easier
for me to get a ring right so i don't
know that might be a better scenario
yeah i think for me i i was not
expecting
this at all uh going in and like having
to date somebody else's partner
and really think about a life with them
i mean no one can prepare for that so it
definitely took some adjusting but yeah
overall it was it was a unique
experience yeah shanique what did it
mean for you to see
madeleine and randall click
like almost right off the bat i mean i i
have to imagine that
as comfortable as you might feel in a
relationship watching something like
that happen is scary yeah so there are
two parts to it right i mean the first
part is definitely like okay well
that happened pretty quickly like what
what is what's that about is it just
like an instant chemistry is it because
you guys have similar personalities like
what is it um so that kind of caught me
off guard i think at first i was just
like looking at it like hmm
well you know i don't know if we
necessarily had that quick of a
um you know connection because we were
friends first so it wasn't romantic for
a while but the second part of it is
that
i guess in hindsight i'm looking at him
thinking well maybe that was his version
of trying you know like i'm going to
really put my all into this experience
like i'm going to actually try to date
this person and see what that could look
like
and
figure out what i need you know from my
partner my original partner being me and
and you know i don't know it's two ends
of it right just
trying to figure out you know what how
to make it work yeah randall what was it
about madeleine that you felt you guys
clicked so well together um i think for
one we both were brought on to the
ultimatum we were both given the
ultimatum so we kind of had a lot to
relate to in that aspect and
the fact that we were just able to
we had a lot in common just based off of
likes what we didn't like in a
relationship and i think we were just
able to have really good conversation in
the short period of time that we were
speed dating so which in turn allowed us
to kind of be like okay you know you're
my person for this these three weeks
let's kind of like
work on uh ourselves but like let's not
try to be too hard on each other because
we realize that like
you know there there's there are ways to
grow without
you know being mean or matching each
other and i think that's kind of how our
approach was
um and ultimately i think it kind of it
worked out i think yeah and plus she
thought you were cute so it worked
but i gotta admit like she was throwing
she was throwing game at you hard from
the very beginning and good on you for i
guess not taking the
uh not playing that game but
um
what was your
you know what did your time with zay
teach you about
you know about randall because it there
was that moment where i could feel like
i could see it switch we were like oh
you know whatever the grass is always
greener and then you got over the other
side you're like this grass is not
greener over here
grass i'm looking to agree yeah um i
definitely appreciated um randall a lot
more i think after that experience and
not that i didn't before but i think
um like definitely like dating someone
else who has such a
different personality
puts things into perspective right so
randall's definitely a lot more patient
just kinder i think in general like his
just
one of the kindest people i think i know
so um i definitely was able to
appreciate that about him and just the
way that he carries himself the way that
he speaks the way he's able to kind of
articulate what he's feeling um
definitely kind of came out of the
ultimatum for sure this is an
uncomfortable question to ask but
obviously there's some
late night footage
of you guys what was that conversation
like between you and randall i mean i
don't know if either of you expected
once you realize this this is the
circumstances to go in that route but as
i said randall did not play in
madeleine's game so i no one can follow
you but i feel like that has to be a
hard thing to admit and then to see and
watch back
oh yeah it was it was horrible to watch
um but i think
um and i'll let i guess randall kind of
chime into i want to speak for him but
um
i think
when randall and i talked about the
experience we knew that there was going
to be some sort of romantic component to
it right like some sort of physical
attraction
where both
physical people i guess randall and i so
i think we we had an understanding at
least that
kissing and some touching and stuff that
that might happen my like rule is
be honest with me like let's address it
and just talk about it and if it's
something that you just can't move past
then you can't move past it but that's
the approach that i took like as soon as
we got back together um that was the
first conversation that
randall and i had and it was tough but i
think no one knew what anybody did in
their relationship
and
i mean i thought you know what at least
i'm being honest and upfront with him
and that's how he took it as well and we
just kind of were able to work through
it randall
yeah so like shanique said we spoke
about it um the day before we switched
over or the day of us switching over to
each other again
um and obviously it was tough to hear
everybody had their own experiences
physical emotional
mental
so
at first
me being the jealous person i am i was
like god damn like really um and then
obviously we forgave each other and
moved past it so seeing it over again
it didn't surprise me as much and that's
why i can mention it for just being so
apparent and honest about it um because
i could have been that could have been
my first time seeing it that would have
been a different conversation but
yeah i wasn't tripping obviously it
sucked to see it
on video but um you know she expressed
that they obviously didn't have sex it
was just more handsy congratulations on
making it through getting engaged as i
said i was rooting for you guys when's
the wedding when are we doing this
well yay tba
[Music]
you